bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
dans le projet de loi sur le respect de
la présomption d'innocence détention
provisoire rôle de l'avocat et
protection des personnes contre les
excès médiatiques
le rapport de l'onu sur l'algérie
condamne catégoriquement les islamistes
déminage le pouvoir en place à alger à
partir d'aujourd'hui les droits des
cyclistes sont renforcés avec des
mesures concrètes pour les protéger
ainsi des incitations à pratiquer le
vélo une super league de football
réservé aux clubs riches menace
l'actuelle organisation des coupes
d'europe des clubs champions cinéma
sortie aujourd'hui du film train de vie
avec notamment rufus une comédie sur la
shoah c'est en conseil des ministres ce
matin au palais de l'elysée que le
projet de loi sur la présomption
d'innocence présenté par la ministre de
la justice madame elisabeth guigou était
adopté ce projet contient la création
d'un juge de la détention provisoire la
limitation des conditions de placement
en détention provisoire
le renforcement des droits de la défense
au cours de l'instruction ce sont les
principales têtes de chapitre d'un texte
qui est en fait le troisième volet de la
réforme de la justice voulue par le
gouvernement depuis son arrivée au
pouvoir il ya 18 mois
sur ces différents éléments qui seront
proposés au vote parlementaire voici les
explications de thierry curtet et alain
poirier
ce projet de loi est le troisième volet
du grand chantier de la réforme de la
justice elisabeth guigou souhaite
renforcer la présomption d'innocence
sa proposition la plus controversée
retire au juge d'instruction la mise en
détention provisoire
cette décision devrait être selon elle
du ressort du président du tribunal
cet ex place le juge d'instruction en
position d'arbitré impartial entre
l'accusation et la défense
ce que à mon sens il devrait toujours
être il ne doit pas prendre parti il
doit instruire à charge et à décharge
pour trouver la vérité et c'est ce que
ce texte va lui permettre de faire
deuxième aspect la présence de l'avocat
dès la première heure de garde à vue au
lieu de la 20e actuellement un
changement qui n'emballe pas tous les
policiers
ça va modifier beaucoup de choses
puisque c'est pendant les premières
heures et s'étendre après le choc
psychologique de l'interpellation de
l'individu que souvent deux fois on
arrive à obtenir les aveux puisqu'en
france à l'heure actuelle jusqu'à preuve
du contraire il faut toujours avoir la
veut s'il n'est pas indispensable
et quand bien utile pour étayer la le
délit et pour étayer la véracité du
délit on reproche souvent à la justice
d'être lente le projet de loi précise le
droit d'être jugé dans un délai
raisonnable une notion définie par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
un délai qui s'estiment en comparant les
affaires et leur complexité
enfin le texte prévoit d'interdire toute
diffusion d'image portant atteinte à la
dignité d'une victime une amende de 50
mille francs est prévu pour cette
infraction
le président de la république monsieur
jacques chirac a jugées nécessaires ce
projet de loi il a rappelé qu'il avait
souhaité lui-même dès janvier 97
monsieur jospin défendu un texte
d'équilibré touchant la dignité de la
personne humaine
mais là on attend surtout les réactions
des intéressés à savoir policiers
magistrats ces derniers craignent un
surcroît de travail mais madame guigou
assurait ce matin que sur 140 postes de
magistrat créent au budget de l'année
prochaine
plus de la moitié serait consacrée à des
postes de juge de la détention
provisoire alors nous avons choisi le
tribunal de grande instance de tours
pour recueillir les témoignages des
juges face à cette nouvelle réforme qui
les inquiète
reportage valérie ermite et jean-paul
chaussée la souricière des cellules dans
un palais de justice
c'est l'un que les prévenus at en avant
d'être présenté à un juge d'instruction
cet homme en détention provisoire depuis
huit mois pour trafic d'héroïne
rencontre le juge qui doit se prononcer
sur son maintien en détention
parce que des vérifications sont en
cours
il restera en prison à l'avenir cette
décision n'appartiendrait plus au juge
d'instruction mais à un nouveau juge
celui de la détention un juge avec un
regard nouveau mais un juge qui
connaîtra forcément moins bien un
dossier
les magistrats disent attention ça peut
donner lieu à des décisions par exemple
dans lesquels une personne sera relâché
par un juge qui a mis peut avoir pris
une connaissance trop rapide du dossier
lui laissera-t-on le temps les moyens
l'énergie en fin de journée ennuis en
week-end le d'étudier parfaitement un
dossier complexe celui sur lequel j'ai
statuer aujourd'hui fait trois tomtom c
c'est ça ce n'est pas la première fois
que le législateur tente de réformer les
compétences et les pouvoirs des juges
d'instruction une nouvelle réforme
pourquoi pas 10 et magistrats mais la
grande majorité craint d'y perdre en
efficacité
à force d'émietter les compétences ou si
vous voyez vous pariez le pouvoir ou ses
pouvoirs on risque de créer plus de
difficultés donc on ne résoudra oui au
président du tribunal lui a fait ses
comptes
c'est lui ou un vice président qui sera
juste de la détention et pour l'instant
il dit ne pas pouvoir assumer cette
nouvelle charge de travail
à l'heure actuelle c'est une
impossibilité absolue absolue à tour
comme ailleurs si les moyens et le
personnel supplémentaire ne suivent pas
cette réforme sera plus que difficile à
appliquer le projet de loi vise aussi à
protéger les personnes contre les excès
médiatiques et notamment vise à
interdire la diffusion d'image de
personnes menottées
il existe déjà dans le code de procédure
pénale un article un complément sous
forme de circulaire général rappelant
les conditions du port des menottes mais
le projet va plus loin et aurait donc
concrètement des conséquences dans le
traitement de l'actualité dans la presse
commentaire de me garder gyan
les menottes on ne les voit pas on les
devine cela suffit pour le guide de
haute montagne mise en examen et écrouée
après l'avalanche mortelle d or le mal
est fait le soir de la diffusion de
cette image la télévision les pousses du
deed a dit à ses enfants
voyez comment la justice traite votre
papa autre image l'abbé cottard
soupçonnés d'être responsables de la
mort de cinq jeunes scouts cet été même
infraction que le guide mais la pad
monop sous la soutane
l'image peut être diffusés sans problème
publié une image d'une personne entre
avait alors qu'elle n'a pas été jugée
sera puni d'une amende de 100 mille
francs
alors question masquer les menottes par
un simple trucage ou recadrer l'image
sera-t-il suffisant pour les avocats
cette interdiction est une avance
indéniable pour la défense j'allais dire
tant pis pour vous parce que c'est vrai
que ça va vous privez d'image mais met
les menottes c'est le sceau de l'infamie
s'est fait faire comprendre au public
que l'on est suspect donc que l'on est
coupable et je crois que la lave c'est
vrai qu'il ya une avancée fantastique
l'arrestation du pédophile marc dutroux
l'image et tournai en belgique elle ne
pourra pas être diffusé en france la
justice est un bon spectacle écrivait-on
en 91 aujourd'hui le respect de la vie
privée est devenue priorité mais plus
supportable à cause d'un concept
relativement récent qui est celui du
respect la bp qui date de 1910 et ça
c'est une innovation
je l'imaginais d'un mouvement de 68 que
comme moi vous avez bien connu aussi et
que le respect de l'individu la montée
de l'individualisme
si le projet de loi d'elisabeth guigou
est adoptée par le parlement
il ne nous sera plus possible de
diffuser ces images de raph et
d'arrestations
dominique vous nous l'avez rappelé j'ai
pris mon code de procédure pénale ça
existe déjà article 803 7
cette mesure non mais vous êtes bonne
lecture simplement on oublie un peu cet
article parce que c'est le dernier
peut-être du code de procédure pénale et
limite le port des menottes
celui-ci se justifie soit en cas de
dangerosité l'individu soins en cas de
risque de fuite
et dans la pratique les notes sont
devenus systématiques pour le chef d'
escort c'est une sécurité or dans le cas
du guide de haute montagne cela ne se
justifiait nullement les menottes c'est
aussi la volonté des enquêteurs de
frapper l'opinion délibérément la
justice offre une image infamante
aujourd'hui dans son projet de loi il
avait dit goût interdit ces images elle
responsabilise aussi le chef d' escort
il devra veiller personnellement à ce
qu'aucune image de personnes entravé ne
soient tournés alors on arrive au vrai
débat qui nous concerne entre la
présomption d'innocence qui doit être
respecté et qu'il droit à l'information
lui demain il y aura ce que l'on pourra
dire est ce que l'on pourra pas montré
oui au poids des mots non au choc des
photos pour reprendre un célèbre slogan
publicitaire journalistes de l'image
nous pouvons cad m est acceptée ce
respect de la présomption d'innocence
mais la justice reste que d'être prise à
son tour à son propre piège
comment informer par exemple l'opinion
de l'arrestation de l'ennemi public
numéro un nous devrons travailler
différemment
dont acte la justice elle sera peut-être
à la recherche d'une nouvelle image de
marque
puis dominique va ce problème vous
concerne vous téléspectateurs alors si
vous voulez nous faire part de vos
réactions
voici les coordonnées de notre médiateur
dans l'addiction
didier epelbaum avec la bresse 7 et cela
marie de france
et puis l'adresse internet également si
vous voulez vous faire faire donc de vos
commentaires de vos réactions
à bastia l'ancien président du conseil
général de haute-corse monsieur paul
natali a été mis en examen pour
favoritisme ainsi que son fils ils ont
été laissés en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire il aurait bénéficié selon les
premières investigations judiciaires
d'une prise illégale d'intérêt au moment
de l'attribution de deux marchés publics
dunkerque hier les douaniers ont opéré
une saisie très important de cigarettes
de contrebande regardez bien seaton 400
de cigarettes été transporté dans un
camion venant de grèce via l'italie à
destination du marché des grands
autant on remarque ce trafic de
cigarettes danse développé la france est
un pays de transit les risques pour les
transporteurs sont évidemment moins
grands dès lors qu'il ne s'agit pas de
drogue mais de paquets de cigarettes
c'est ce soir est sans doute tard dans
la nuit que les militants de l'udf
connaîtront le nom de leur quatrième
président je dire quatrième depuis la
fondation par monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing de l'union pour la démocratie
française c'était en 1978 il n'y a pas
de suspense ce sera françois bayrou
celui ci devra sa présidence pour la
première fois au vote direct des
adhérents
reportage carole caumont et marianne
masse c'est une première
des militants de l'udf sont appelés à
élire directement leur nouveau président
160 bureaux de vote comme ici dans la
région de lille et trois candidats en
lice pour un scrutin dont le résultat
s'annonce pourtant sans surprise hier
soir c'est dans une brasserie parisienne
que le grand favori
françois bayrou a clôturé sa campagne
auprès des militants
avec le soutien de françois léotard le
président sortant qui laisse aujourd'hui
une udf revient mal en point et s'efface
sur l'air de la contrition
si je n'ai pas été toujours ce que vous
attendiez que je sois pardonnez moi
c'est possible je me suis efforcé de le
faire avec dignité avec la conviction
que l'udf est irremplaçable dans la vie
politique nationale
une passation de pouvoir avant l'heure
sous l'oeil sceptique d'un des autres
candidats à la présidence
un proche de charles millon et devant
des militants parfois excédé par les
divisions qui déchirent aujourd'hui
l'opposition et les mêmes vous parlait
toujours de vos parties de vos
structures on s'en fout de vos
structures interdisent libre de parler
des jo tu as les nouveaux programmes et
après ça on vous le suivrez vous avez du
mal m'écouter parce que j'ai dit
beaucoup moins brillamment que vous
naturellement ce que vous venez de dire
à l'instant
arrêtons de parler des autres défendons
nos idées sous notre drapeau et alors
nous avons une chance de reconquérir
l'opinion qui nous attend un pari
difficile affaibli par le départ des
libéraux d'alain madelin toujours en
proie à des querelles internes
l'udf vingt ans après sa création je
désormais sa survie
voilà et nous recevrons demain dans ce
journal monsieur françois bâillon près
de rennes à noyal-sur-vilaine le
ministère et culture monsieur louis le
pensec qui visitait une exploitation
agricole a estimé que les mesures de
soutien aux producteurs de porcs décidé
hier par le comité européen de gestion
la viande porcine à bruxelles n'était
pas suffisante
le compte n'y est pas a dit ministre
tandis que les éleveurs de lait
réclament des aides directes et rapide
aujourd'hui le cours du porc était
encore en dessous des 6 francs et les
jeunes agriculteurs sont déçus du peu
d'engagement des pouvoirs publics pour
comprendre la crise qui atteint les
éleveurs de porcs vos cils en quête d'
eric mézil jacques devaux et michel
levasseur
la france a une ombre a besoin d'avoir
pris quatre cent mille têtes on peut pas
dire celle qui est des fautifs les pays
qu'il faut viser le plus ce sont les
hollandais sont les espagnols les
allemands qui commencera vraiment c'est
les autres
l'explication est un peu court car ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est un peu
la chronique d'une crise annoncée
marchés mondiaux qui se ferme
consommation au point mort
ports américains bien moins cher comme
en 93 et en 90 il ya surproduction mais
entre chaque crise les cours remonte
alors en bretagne ou ailleurs on en
profite pour développer des élevages
toujours plus grand toujours plus
intensif une démarche encouragée par le
crédit agricole retournement a eu lieu
je pense que dans la longue période
l'outil français est performant il doit
le rester il doit continuer de se
développer
résultat huit cent mille tonnes de porc
attentes dans les frigos européens de
trouver preneur les éleveurs certains
éleveurs d'or sortir de cette logique
situation là elle est intenable
elle rapporte à toute une logistique
autour de nous une agro-industrie et
elles ne rapportent plus aux paysans
et puis la société n'en veut plus
aujourd'hui ministre de l'agriculture en
tête certains posent la question
ne faut-il pas limiter la production en
instaurant des quotas tous les pays la
communauté européenne s'accordent pour
dire on diminue tous de temps pour cent
pour revenir à un haut niveau souhaité
donc s'il faut abattre des porcelets en
bretagne mais il faut que les espagnols
en a batu si il faut que tout le monde
joue le jeu on retrouve sa part à peine
une limitation de la production qui
répondrait également un souci
d'environnement chaque jour 23 mille
tonnes de lisier sont produits en
bretagne à tunis on efface fixiez par
l'odeur à guingamp ne peut plus boire
l'eau du robinet le producteur de porc
doit affronter cette réalité là aussi
publication aujourd'hui du rapport de la
mission d'information de l'onu sur
l'algérie cette mission remplie par six
personnalités dont l'ancien président
portugais monsieur mario soares ainsi
que madame simone veil s'était effectuée
entre le 22 juillet le 4 août dernier en
algérie
le rapport condamne catégoriquement les
islamistes et note que les autorités
d'alger se sont rendus coupables de
violations des droits de l'homme
mais ces deux appréciations ne peuvent
pas être mises sur le même plan selon
l'onu les organisations non
gouvernementales dont amnesty
international ont le sentiment que le
pouvoir en place à alger a été ménagé
reportage patrice romedenne bruno
girodon du rapport onusien la presse
algérienne parle en termes réconfortant
pour le pouvoir en place
de fait le gouvernement juge le rapport
positif et se félicite de son contenu
souviendrai très certainement que des
doutes ont été exprimés sur source du
terrorisme en jeu ses auteurs le rapport
vient de ce point de vue faire une zone
est catégorique
depuis 1992 entre 60 et 100 mille
personnes sont mortes en algérie
transformant le blay dans un cimetière
dont on ignore les limites dernier
massacre en date
avant-hier ici dans le village de zoug à
la au terrorisme aurait pour la violence
des forces de l'ordre les missionnaires
de l'onu s'en émeuvent mais un peu trop
mollement au goût des organisations
humanitaires
oui il y a quelque chose qui choque en
ce rapport c'est qu'il indique qu'il ne
faut pas mettre sur le même pied
la violence des terroristes et la
violence
de l'état algérien c'est vrai qu'il faut
pas me renvoyer dos à dos
mais cette présentation de l'impression
que on légitime les moyens y compris les
les pires de répression systématique et
féroce utilisé par les autorités
algériennes et cela nous paraît très
inquiétant en débarquant à alger au mois
de juillet dernier la mission
d'information n'avait sans doute pas
l'intention de froisser le pouvoir
algérien sur ce point elle a réussi pour
le reste parce qu'elle n'a pas pu
rencontrer qui elle souhaitait notamment
les dirigeants de l'ex fils la mission
laisse bien des questions sans réponse
à commencer par celle que posent ces
femmes réunis ce soir devant l'organisme
national des droits de l'homme à alger
leurs proches ont été enlevés pourquoi
par qui mystère en albanie après trois
journées d'émeutes et d'affrontements
entre les partisans de l'ex président
sali berisha et les forces de l'ordre
le bilan établi par les autorités à
tirana la capitale albanaise serait de
huit morts et 80 blessés
aujourd'hui nouvelle manifestation
pacifique cette fois rassembler les
partisans de monsieur berisha toujours
menacés de poursuites par le
gouvernement albanais reportage à tirana
jérôme boni patrick desmulie avec
françois cornet quatre jours après
l'assassinât du député ajdari
l'opposition manifestent toujours
bravant l'interdiction des autorités
albanaises
acclamations pour sali berisha l'ancien
président que le pouvoir accuse de
tentative de coup d'état dans la garde
rapprochée de berisha sali et hazem
originaire du nord de l'albanie comme
l'ancien président supporte un véritable
siège dans les locaux du parti
démocratique
regardez il y à là bas deux tireurs
embusqués qui veulent nous éliminer
pour les opposants berisha reste celui
qui a mis fin en 91 à 50 ans de
communisme stalinien
cette fantaisie mais ceux qui ont de
l'ogcn de roda propres aussi alors
baisser le nez au dictateur et sa clique
hier encore il y avait deux chars au
siège du parti démocratique ils ont été
restitués au ministère de l'intérieur et
les jeunes rambo ont apparemment accepté
de déposer les armes ce que berisha
traite de néo communistes les
socialistes ont repris la situation en
main dans le palais du premier ministre
les gardes du corps sont originaires eux
du sud de l'albanie devant les traces
des combats de lundi le premier ministre
se fait menaçant on va simplement
éliminé avec des moyens légaux
avec la force de la loi des chambres où
l'on provoque en réalité pas seulement
mon potentiel des attaques criminelles
contre ya démocratie en albanie
aujourd'hui le calme est revenu dans les
rues de tirana au prix nu dissuasion
armée la police est omniprésente
en iran à téhéran en retour de deux
diplomates iraniens qui avaient réussi à
échapper alors qu'il se trouvait en
afghanistan mazar i sharif aux miliciens
talibans mais à la frontière avec
l'afghanistan les menace d'affrontements
militaires sont toujours très forte
des dizaines de milliers d'hommes sont
mobilisés même si de part et d'autre à
téhéran comme à kaboul on affirme
vouloir privilégier la négociation
explication laurent boussier l'armée
iranienne en état d' alerte maximum qui
envoie neuf divisions
deux cent mille hommes près de sa
frontière avec l'afghanistan le régime
taliban qui annonce de son côté avoir
massé 25 mille combattants sur la même
frontière chaque jour la tension monte
entre téhéran et les talibans moment
fort le retour il ya deux jours des
corps de sept diplomates iraniens tués à
mazar i sharif lors de la prise de la
ville par les talibans surenchère
nationaliste ou chronique d'une guerre
annoncée les iraniens ont juré de
répondre à cette provocation
une mission difficile d'autant qu'en
afghanistan les chiite allié de téhéran
sont régulièrement massacrés et recule
depuis plusieurs semaines face aux
milices talibans il ya trois jours il
perdait un de leurs derniers bastions
la ville de bam yam après deux très rude
combat reste évidemment l'option
militaire une opération punitive est
toujours envisageable mais elle devra
être limitée dans le temps
l'équilibré des forces est évidemment en
faveur des iraniens mais comme les
russes il ya presque vingt ans ils
craignent qu'une intervention en
afghanistan ne les conduise à un
enlisement militaire
les iraniens essaieront donc jusqu'au
bout les voies politiques diplomatiques
et internationales
mais il reste prêt à recourir si
nécessaire à la force aux états unis à
washington on annonce des auditions
publiques sur l'affairé lewinsky au
congrès sans doute début octobre
d'autre part les parlementaires
républicains veulent qu'obtenir
peut-être dès demain la diffusion d'une
cassette vidéo montrant le président
bill clinton lors de son audition face
aux questions du procureur kenneth starr
ce soir à 21h heure française le
président des états unis s'adressera
pour la première fois depuis le début de
cette affaire aux journalistes dans une
salle de la maison blanche
monsieur clinton semble encore
bénéficier d'une majorité depuis
favre a parmi ses concitoyens
l'électorat féminin américain lui est
encore acquis même si les critiques et
les marques de déceptions sont
nombreuses reportage de notre
correspondant
philippe gassot pour être élu aux états
unis et cela bill clinton l'a bien
compris il faut chercher la femme elle
représente ici 52% des électeurs
et parmi elles 50 4 % ont choisi bill
clinton en 1996
la femme est l'avenir de l'homme
politique le rapport star a déstabilisé
l'édifice du président bien aimé qui
semblait indestructible
je le soutiens pour ce qu'il c'est faux
le pays n'est pas pour sa moralité
quelles que soient ses excuses ça ne
changera pas ce qu'il a fait il faudra
bien qu'ils paient les conséquences de
ses actes je pense qu'ils vont toute
cette affaire les personnes étaient
consentantes je ne vois pas pourquoi les
femmes devraient s'en mêler c'est bien
là toute la question les féministes
doivent-elles se mêler d'une relation
consentante entre adultes même si elle a
eu lieu à la maison blanche
les lézards de commencent à apparaître
notamment ici à la national organization
for women
n/o ewc 250000 adhérentes n'accepte pas
tout
la version officielle de la présidence
ce qu'a fait bill clinton c'est
totalement inacceptable complètement
inapproprié pour reprendre ses propres
termes
mais ça n'est pas une faute qui entraîne
une destitution
je ne pense pas que ce soit dans
l'intérêt du pays qu'il démissionne on
essaie chez nord éviter les pièges
politiques afin de rester sur les
questions de principe réduire une
relation entre deux personnes
consentantes à des problèmes de moralité
et l'éthique c'est vraiment du
maccarthysme sexuelle
les adhérentes de virginie exige le
départ de clinton et aussi de la
présidente de l'association qui le
défend nous voulons la démission de
ancien et de son équipe parce qu'elle a
transformé cette organisation est une
organisation nationale de menteuse
l'édifice féminin du vote démocrate se
fissure mais devrait tenir au moins
jusqu'en novembre prochain date des
élections à moins d'un coup de théâtre
et l'on pense aux bandes vidéo à
l'enregistrement du président clinton
qui a été présenté devant le grand jury
on sait qu'il n'y ait pas toujours à son
avantage est ici aux etats unis
l'image la télévision c'est essentiel à
l'hôpital necker à paris
un essai de traitement de la
mucoviscidose à l'aide d'un médicament
la colchicine vient d'être lancée la
mucoviscidose est la plus fréquente des
maladies génétiques héréditaires graves
de l'enfant elle touche des garçons des
filles dont les parents sont tous deux
porteurs d'une anomalie génétique en
france plus de 2 millions de personnes
sont susceptibles de transmettre cette
maladie les résultats de cet essai ne
seront disponibles que dans un an et
demi
au moins il convient d'être très
prudents quant à l'espérance de réussite
reportage benoît thevenet andré germain
cette île des séances de kiné
respiratoire pour soulager ses bons la
mucoviscidose ne laisse pas de rythme
jusqu'à maintenant les recherches
s'orientent est du côté de la thérapie
génique
c'est à dire un remplacement du gène
responsable de la maladie
ces derniers mois d'autres chercheurs se
sont tournés vers la recherche
médicamenteuse est une situation
fortuite qui est à la base de leurs
travaux en kinésithérapie chez un
patient atteint de mucoviscidose et qui
avait à la fois un cancer il a été mis
sous anti cancéreux est aussi rendu
compte que sa fonction respiratoire
avait été notablement amélioré son
anticancéreux le but des recherches en
laboratoire a donc été de comprendre le
phénomène et d'envisager une hypothèse
de traitement est possible de remplacer
la protéine qui ne fonctionne pas pour
des raisons d'origine génétique
alors des protéines voisine peu
l'organisme normalement une utilise très
peu et dont on peut déclencher la
production en grande quantité à l'aide
de différentes molécules sur un
médicament en particulier et qu'on
produit anticancéreux
si cette protéine qui est en cause les
essais thérapeutiques comme en cette
semaine de la colchicine un médicament
bien connu va être administrés pendant
plusieurs mois à 85 enfants une voie de
recherche évoqué avec prudence par la
communauté scientifique par le passé de
nombreuses pistes qui s'avérait
prometteuse n'ont pas tenu leurs
promesses et nous ne devons pas en
pensant particulièrement aux enfants et
aux familles qui sont en souffrance une
attente susciter de faux espoirs
quoi qu'il en soit il faudra attendre
plusieurs années avant l'arrivée d'un
éventuel médicaments et seule la
thérapie génique permettra de traiter
totalement la maladie je rappelle que
les virades de l'espoir organisées par
l'association française de lutte contre
la mucoviscidose c'est dimanche prochain
parution au journal officiel aujourd'hui
d'un décret renforçant les droits des
cyclistes les pistes cyclables seront
entièrement réservé excluant les
cyclomoteurs de plus on pourra circuler
un vélo sur les voies piétonnes et les
enfants seront privilégiés toutes ces
décisions visent à améliorer également
la protection des cyclistes car c'est
pas facile de lutter contre l'automobile
reportage benoît mousset didier rancoeur
faciliter la vie des cyclistes et
surtout mieux les protéger vos cils
objectifs ambitieux du décret car le
vélo aujourd'hui loin d'être reconnu
comme un moyen de transport à part
entier première initiative les pistes et
bandes cyclables sont maintenant des
aménagements exclusivement réservée la
discipline autre nouveauté la
circulation des deux roues dont les
zones piétonnières est autorisée avant
elles n'étaient que tolérer une
disposition qui ne peut que réjouir cet
utilisateur
voilà je suis dans une rue piétonne est
donc maintenant j'ai le droit de faire
du vélo dans la rue piétonne
comme contre ici pas de leurs biens la
torture et on est maintenant si le maire
de la ville d'och que je ne fasse pas de
vélo il faudra qu'il intervient alors
que jusqu'à maintenant ce qu'elle contre
elle le décrit encourage également les
communes à aménager des espaces sur la
chaussée devant les feux de
signalisation afin que les cyclistes
soient mieux protégés jusqu'à maintenant
c'est ça n'avait pas d'existence légale
et à partir de maintenant on peut
verbaliser les automobilistes qui
s'arrêteront sur la zone qui en fait
réservé ont soutenu un quatrième point
sans doute celui qui sera le plus
discuté permis désormais aux enfants de
moins de 8 ans de rouler sur les
trottoirs et d'apprendre à paris 6ème la
bicyclette
voilà pour l'instant ma petite fille
elle est encore petit mais plus tard
j'aimerais bien quelqu'un de puissant
faire l'an dernier 329 cyclistes sont
morts sur les routes se décrit devrait
rendre la pratique du vélo en ville
moins dangereuses
à condition que les automobilistes
consentants fun et c'est un peu de place
au petit frère ado
sport football mais on devra dire aussi
argent football puisque le projet d'une
super ligue européenne de football née
dans l'esprit de financiers ayant
constaté que le ballon rapporter gros
divise ceux qui veulent préserver ce
sport des intérêts mercantiles
en clair il s'agit de créer une
compétition parallèle réservé avec
l'ofppt privilégiés tels marseille psg
en france barcelone real de madrid en
espagne milan ac notamment en italie et
d'organiser ainsi des rencontres
susceptibles de rassembler beaucoup de
spectateurs dans les stades des airs de
recueillir des droits télévisés
colossaux quant au petit même s'ils sont
champions de leur pays tels auxerre lens
ou nantes
mais il en serait ksc enquête laurent
frédéric bollée claude bernier
billon vainqueur des anglais de
blackburn hier soir en coupe d'europe un
but extraordinaire une grande émotion
depuis plus de 40 ans est le lot de
madère des soirs d'europe
oui mais les coupes d'europe justement
il se pourrait que bientôt on doive les
regarder comme ça
la super league on en parle de plus en
plus et les riches télévisions privées
n'y sont pas étrangères
les coupes d'europe traditionnels
pourraient disparaître très vite le
débat est déjà lancé
je suis contre parce que je pense que ça
ça nuirait à tous les atouts les
championnats nationaux
c'est tout pour le beau football et les
grands événements donc à partir de là je
crois qu'on y arrivera de toute manière
marcel desailly champion d'europe
marseille milan presse donc pour un
renforcement de l'élite une élite qui
existe en fait déjà acquis sous
l'impulsion d'un homme rodolfo est tente
de monter une supercoupe d'europe très
lucrative c'est italien de 44 ans ancien
bras droit de silvio berlusconi fédère
les projets de 16 grands clubs européens
trois anglais mais aussi deux français
trois italiens 2 espagnol un portugais
deux allemands un néerlandais un grec et
à turc à coup de réunions secrètes et
d'information fracassante le projet de
la superleague avance très vite nous
mettons au point une compétition où
selon nous il n'y aura pas de perdant ce
pour les clubs ce sera des rentrées
financières en hausse et pour le public
des matchs de meilleure qualité dette
mortgage aux prôné t il distille les
informations ils font une communication
goutte à goutte et ça je trouve que
c'est très intelligent parce que ça fait
revenir sur l'information tous les jours
ce point un grand coup une fois et on en
parle plus c'est toutes les semaines
quelque chose
et ma foi c'est bien fait ils font leurs
réunions secrètes comme ça ça excite le
monde bien c'est à nous de nous
organiser
secrètement et en plein jour pour
contrer ça pour les faire rentrer au
bercail dans les cartons de médias
partenaires figurent en fait deux
projets de coupes d'europe la super
league et la pro cup pour le reste or et
on me dit
la superleague regrouperait en deux
divisions les 16 clubs fondateurs donc
plus 16 autres qualifiés en fonction de
leurs résultats sportifs le rouge de la
télévision est primordial manchester
united
et après tout de lancer sa propre chaîne
pour la super league les droits de
retransmission serait renégociée chaque
club recevrait au moins 170 millions de
francs par an le vainqueur obtenant plus
de 400 millions au final cinq fois plus
qu'actuellement
un vrai pactole derrière la super league
se profile donc l'ombre des grands
opérateurs privés comme le magnat
australien rupert murdoch qui vient
justement de racheter une partie de
manchester l'uefa de son côté propose
des réformes
chacun s'affrontent au nom des grands
principes c'est l'argent qui décidera
il est hors de question d'imaginer que
les règles qu'ils règlent ce type
d'épreuve la répartition des sommes les
enjeux
sont présents soient discutées et
décidées en dehors de la vie des clubs
parce que les sponsors la télévision
doivent être au service du football doit
retirer des profils ce qu'elle fout mais
en aucun cas ils ne doivent êtes à la
tête des organisations donc tout ligue
nationale tout fédération doit combattre
ce genre d'idée les coupes d'europe de
football ce sont déjà les meilleurs
joueurs les meilleurs matchs les
meilleures audiences sportive du vieux
continent
il est donc tentant d'en vouloir encore
plus la super league est là pour ça
quitte à balayer des décennies de
tradition
cyclisme suite des affaires de dopage ce
soir un choix un soigneur belge de
l'équipe cycliste la française des jeux
a été placé en garde à vue devrait être
bien examen dans la sphère des produits
dopants de l'équipe festina cinéma
aujourd'hui mercredi sortie dans les
salles notamment d'un film de radu
mihaileanu train de vie une histoire qui
raconte la shoah mais c'est aussi une
comédie une vision humoristique dans la
ligne ouverte par roberto bellini avec
la vie est belle dans train de vie le
réalisateur un français d'origine juive
roumaine a fait jouer le rôle principal
à rufus reportage daniel wolfromm
patrick voit un convoi de déportés qui
file dans la campagne
un nouveau film sur l'holocauste mais
celui ci n'est pas tout à fait comme les
autres
le train non plus d'ailleurs organisé
nous mène au train des déportations
génial telle idée c'est la somme est tué
chambre tu finiras riches
comment tu t'appelles mon métier 1941
dans une bourgade juifs d'europe de
l'est shlomo le fou du village à l'idée
saugrenue pour sauver sa communauté de
la sphère des portés par elle même mais
vers la russie vrais juifs encadrés par
de faux nazis respectueux comme les
autres de la prière du shabbat
ça suffit que vous ayez reçu bon terme
aux uniformes n'est pas question nos
têtes sont couvertes
il est lu par écrit qu'il soit interdit
de se couvrir de chapeau nazis
une association juive avait organisé une
projection succès sans ambiguïté à
l'image de cette dame qui a été déporté
plus d'un an elle a applaudi comme le
reste de la salle au ton du film et à
son humour si particulier avec un groupe
de filles on nous étions à oka ensuite
chaque fois qu'ils qu'on pouvait lire de
quelque chose ça nous apporte chaleur
intérieure
en face nous avons chaque jour de braise
allemand alors il faut un vrai chef
ahmad et allemand font la prière avec
une répète la même chose que moi je vais
te reconnaîtras l'allemand sap allons
tenir en avant publiant un livre à la
main
on n'a pas arrêté de faire ce film avec
des garde fous et on s'est surtout
interdit beaucoup de choses pour nous
pour que ça ne soit pas récupérée par
des négationnistes des révisionnistes le
front national est plein de gens de ce
genre est depuis charlie chaplin
lubitsch et mel brooks l'humour juif et
le rire sont bien l'antidote à la
tragédie a su respecter un maillot à
l'appui un salut amical dans les
kiosques ce matin pour deux nouveaux
quotidiens l'as et pour les 6 9 ans le
petit quotidien et l'autre pour les
14-18 ans l'actif qualité garantie car
c'est l'équipe de nos quotidiens qui a
fêté en janvier dernier trois ans
d'existence qui proposent ces deux
nouveaux journaux pour la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle le principe à
l'information le dépôt du projet de loi
et l'adoption du projet de loi cette
ministre de madame guigou concernant la
présomption d'innocence modifiant les
conditions de mise en détention et le
renforcement des droits de la défense
dans quelques instants vous retrouver
isabelle martinet pour les biens de
nouvelles de la météo de plus en plus
beau jusqu'à dimanche promet-elle à
20h50 passion interdite un téléfilm est
didier sandre et caroline sihol suivi de
ça se discute à zéro heure 35 florence
duprat pour le dernier journal suivi du
cercle présenté par philippe lefait
demain c'est 1,50 françoise laborde
recevra dans les 4 vérités gilles de
robien le député maire d'amiens à 13h
carole gaessler rachid arhab à 2
20h bonsoir merci
je